time now for the verizon 5g
speed round christopher and we're going
to focus on the afc matchups in week 17
in a what's more likely
format let's get right to it the miami
dolphins at 10 and 5 trying desperately
to get into the postseason they could be
the cheese that stands alone in the afc
they are at the buffalo bills what's
more likely ryan fitzpatrick goes fits
magic and has one touchdown or your boy
blue josh allen has three touchdowns
what's more like it's like it's tough
just because we don't really know what
buffalo's gonna do right that's where
it's like i i don't know are they gonna
play the full game like we talked about
all week if i'm buffalo my number one
goal this week is just to avoid
baltimore in the first round of the
while the wild card playoffs that that's
really what i'd be worried about i'd
play to beat i'd play to beat the
dolphins and maybe be scored board
watching and once you saw maybe the
browns were beating the pittsburgh
steelers and maybe going to win the game
you take them out i don't know i think
if i'm going to choose either one here
i'm going to go josh allen has three tds
i i don't feel comfortable about that
but i just there's no guarantee
fitzpatrick gets in the game and what if
the dolphins play they're good defensive
run game bootlegs like we've seen them
be when they are successful with tuba
that could be a possibility and
fitzpatrick never gets in so i'm going
to go with alan and three tds
yeah look i i really do believe that the
bills need to keep
building the momentum that you've seen
grow and grow and grow the past several
weeks and i agree with you you ideally
would like to avoid the baltimore ravens
but i don't know how much of that you
can actually engineer by choosing to
play to win or not win there's still
benefit in knocking out a division rival
yep and the dolphins would not get in if
they would lose and baltimore wins
cleveland wins against a pittsburgh team
that won't be playing ben roethlisberger
and the colts win
over the jaguars that's what keeps the
miami dolphins out and right now i think
that they are going to be the one that
is left out for as good as they've been
and as as
dramatically as this team has turned
around it's going to be one more year
until they get to the playoffs i fear
back in week two josh allen had four
touchdowns against the miami dolphins in
that 31-28 victory by buffalo over miami
all right my i was just one thing well
just to say with that too i mean i you
know just looking at it to like what you
said to keep the pedal on the metal do
all that i think when you really look at
it the best way for them to avoid
baltimore is just to win the game
because i think that's the less likely
scenario that baltimore will end up
being in as the seven seed is like the
least likely thing so that to me you win
the game great you keep the momentum
going and you ensure you know the least
likely thing of happening which is
baltimore you know or having to deal
with them you know in the in the first
round wild card
the cleveland browns need to get a
victory over the steel as i mentioned
ben roethlisberger won't be playing
it'll be mason rudolph baker miefield
had a bad game against the jets with
multiple fumbles here he is when he was
asked yesterday by mary kay cabot of
cleveland.com about his performance in
week 16.
um
i don't know i've had my back against
the wall many times in my life
i think i handled that type of stuff
correctly um so
just one day at a time till sunday i
can't win it right now
i have to move on from the game and work
to get there
you use it to your advantage we i mean
sometimes a mad baker is a good baker um
no i was thinking i was probably gonna
use it as a disadvantage and uh you know
maybe
drop the ball four more times i don't
know
can't help himself can't help himself
he's suppressed his nature almost all
season he got to week 17. that that's
just who he is whether you like it or
not that's who he is he's a smart ass
and as a card carrying smart ass
i can relate to it but in certain
settings you suppress it and he had
suppressed it in press conferences all
year long he was using quotes from the
office in parks and rec instead he
finally ran out of quotes from other tv
shows and he went back to being a smart
ass chris yeah no he definitely did and
you know that's mary kate cabot who's a
you know a legend in the nfl media and
cleveland you know
following the the browns football team
uh yeah i wish you know he didn't do
that i wish he would come up with just
some funny comment from a show again or
something like that because yeah that
just is a it's a little bit of a low
blow or whatever either way um
but but it's not like it was a
ridiculously stupid question no it was
not
you could give a smart ass answer to 95
percent of the questions that are asked
by people who are just doing their jobs
she is just doing her job as the liaison
between a football team and football fan
and you come off frankly as a punk when
you act that way i'm sorry i said it but
that's how you come off yeah i i i can't
disagree with you there you're you're
right and and you know it is a
legitimate question i mean yeah
turnovers happen you know what is in
your mind this week that's all she was
what's in your mind what's your approach
is there something done at practice to
be a little bit more aware of it
whatever you know is it are you using it
is there something you saw on film where
you didn't have two hands on the ball
listen he fumbled twice last week it
wasn't like it was like egregious where
you're just like how could he fumble and
what an idiot i mean he got crushed both
times blindsided so i mean that's gonna
happen in football especially when you
got tight ends and practice squad people
playing wide receiver and they can't get
open and then you got to pat the ball
and wait because nobody's open and all
of that but you know
yeah listen baker's been awesome all
year long he's playing awesome on the
field uh he can wipe that off totally
he'll be awesome all together
all right so what's more likely miles
garrett gets two or more sacks of his
good friend sarcasm alert mason rudolph
or baker mayfield has at least one
turnover i'm gonna go miles garrett gets
two plus sacks i gotta think in a day
like miles garrett's at quarterback all
right baker mayfield should go okay
their offense has been struggling with
big ben at quarterback i would imagine
it's gonna struggle with mason rudolph
at quarterback so when you play the
pittsburgh steelers one of the parts of
playing them is going wait i'm not going
to let the steelers defense win the
football game by scoring points that's
what he did the first time through a
pick six of the first series of the game
you know the game pittsburgh's defense
won the game before the offense really
ever had to do anything that's part of
playing the steelers so i think he'll
realize that he's been good for the most
part ever since that game other than
last week which i said wasn't
necessarily all his fault i'm going to
go with miles gets the two plus sacks on
mason
cleveland gets in with a victory over
the steelers or an indianapolis loss or
a tennessee loss and a miami win and a
baltimore win and i still don't
understand what has to happen just win
cleveland what do you think is going to
happen there and you're in i think
they're going to win god if they can't
beat the steroids with mason rudolph
they don't belong in the playoffs i know
that but i want to know what you think
two plus sacks or baker mayfield
turnover that's what you asked your
answer oh uh
miles garrett two plus are you kidding
me miles garrett getting a shot at mason
rudolph
uh yeah miles garrett two plus sacks of
mason rudolph on sunday all right uh
titans at the texans what's more likely
derek henry gets to 2 000 rushing yards
or deshawn watson throws four touchdown
passes derek henry needs 223
to get to 2000 and the only guy in the
nfl who could pull off 223 in a week 17
right now is derek henry so will he do
it chris or will desean watson throw
four touchdowns like
he definitely can do it especially
against houston houston is you know
again if your offense is struggling the
doctor orders houston's defense to come
to town that's what the doctor does i
mean but
uh you know there's too much to defend
on the titans offense all together the
titans still got a win you know to to
get in the playoffs they're not
guaranteed of a spot either as we sit
here which is amazing to say out loud
huh
man their defense is so not good to
where i could see desean watson throw
i'm gonna go deshawn watson throws four
touchdowns i am wow i am i'm gonna go
with that i mean 223 is just a little
too much
so i you know i could see him getting
180 something like that but 223 i don't
know if i can put my name to that i
could see watson four tds more realistic
way back in week six henry had 212
rushing yards against the texans but
watson did have four touchdown passes
against tennessee that same week and the
titans have allowed 33 touchdown passes
this year tied for second most horrible
hard hard to feel good about the mike
rabel defense when you've given up that
many touchdown passes all right the
colts one of the other teams that are
intertwined with the tight uh the titans
to see who's going to win the division
jaguars
1 in 14. they started the year with a
win over the colts they've lost 14 in a
row it would be perfect if they would
end the season
beating the colts colts at 10 and 5.
what's more likely philip rivers takes
two or more sacks or he throws three
touchdown passes against the jaguars i'm
gonna go with the three touchdowns here
i'm gonna go with that you know um
i know anthony castanzo's out at left
tackle for the colts that stinks i mean
he is you know one of the better left
tackles in football definitely but the
jacksonville defense
uh you know not a great pass rush not
one single pass rusher that you're
worried about that way they're not good
at defending the pass i would think
rivers is going to find people up and
get the ball out of his hands and they
become a decent running football team
here as of late so with that i'm going
to go with the three touchdowns and and
uh i think that's more more of a
possibility than going more than two
sacks
i mentioned the titans have 33 passing
touchdowns allowed this year tied for
second most in the nfl the other team
tied with them the jaguars with 33
passing touchdowns and look this could
be a dangerous game for the colts
because the jaguars just don't care they
just don't care this is kind of yeah not
that it's a game anyone's going to be
paying attention to it's not in prime
time it's not nationally televised but
the jaguars just don't care and uh the
organization now that they've locked up
the trevor lawrence pick they can uh
they
don't have to try to lose just go all
out see what you can do you know this is
where a team is dangerous the point you
made earlier in the show about the
eagles the jaguars go forward on fourth
down on side kicks fake punt fake field
goal do anything who cares who cares
right what's the difference between 1
and 14 1 and 15 2 and 14 who cares at
this point they have a brighter future
with trevor lawrence let's just go have
some fun i agreed that they are scary
that way and you know with doug marone
and that team too yeah i don't expect
them to be that like we're gonna lay
down type of football team and it's over
no i don't you know jay gruden's done a
good job on the offensive side of the
ball every week they make plays on the
offensive side of the ball and do things
that way too i mean they're they're kind
of a fun watch even though you know
they're going to lose the game it's
always a pretty fun game to watch when
is jacksonville involved but i think
they'll be outmanned here and i think
you know colt's being desperate having
to win and need help all that uh you
know the dam will break at some point
for jacksonville
three years ago all the ravens had to do
was beat the bengals to get into the
playoffs andy dalton had something to
say about that with less than a minute
to play 44 seconds on the clock a
49-yard touchdown pass to tyler boyd and
that was that for the ravens this time
around the ravens need a win and they're
in against the bengals in cincinnati
this time lamar jackson has 80 or more
rushing yards or baltimore's defense has
three takeaways chris what's more like
oh well both are very likely that that's
for sure i i think though the one that i
look at more than anything here is is
uh i think the 80 plus rush yards
i'm gonna go with that i am i am well
you know cincinnati
awesome secondary if this baltimore was
a passing team i'd go oh this is scary
to play cincinnati just like we saw with
pittsburgh a few weeks they got the
studs back there but the run defense
that's another story and it's not very
good and baltimore's got it going right
now they gotta go and we've talked about
it all week you know it's we don't want
to see nobody i wouldn't want to see
them afc playoffs you know they're
starting to pound people in the running
game lamar looks good you know the pass
game is effective enough to at least
where they're putting hollywood brown in
positions to get the ball it's not going
to blow you away but i'm going to go
with the 80 plus rush yards i am um
you know i don't know i just i guess i i
think cincinnati will do their best
three three takeaways is a lot and i
feel better about 80 plus rush yards
lamar jackson has had 80 plus rushing
yards in three of his last four games
but he had two carries for three yards
against the bengals back in week five i
agree with you this is a different team
yeah and last year it was the titans
that disrupted our presumed ravens
chiefs afc championship game i feel like
this year the ravens could disrupt our
presumed bills chiefs afc championship
game by beating one or the other
depending upon how the draw works out in
the afc all right we're going to take a
draft uh we're going to take a draft
we're going to take a draft i'd like to
take it
out we're going to we're going to we're
going to we're gonna take a break right
now we have changed our typical thursday
draft because i hope you're on board
with this we're not doing the matchup
draft because these are all matchups
we've already seen and we've talked
about them we're doing the show me
something this is usually on friday when
you are sound asleep yes when we do the
show me something draft that is what
we're going to do next we're going to
take a draft and then have a break or
take a break and then have a draft of
show me something next here on pft live
pro football talk is brought to you by
verizon the 5g america's been waiting
for
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports